[Music]
all right let's go to Louisville
Kentucky and talk to the BB what's up
Barb hello Hi how are you I'm
outstanding how are you I'm okay I'm
okay thank you so much for taking my
call I really appreciate it of course
and I know it's nervous to call you are
doing great okay thank you it is really
awkward he hey my wife tells me I've
been awkward for years years so you're
all good I didn't mean you were awkward
I'm so sorry oh listen Barb I'm 100%
awkward there is no doubt about it even
in not awkward situations I make just
regular interactions awkward just like
everyone in the booth is like dude I'm
just trying to tell you hello and I'm
like uh one time yeah just I don't know
man so anyway I'm sorry for being so
awkward so nothing you're going to bring
up is gonna make me feel even more
Awkward than I've already made it so
what's up well thank you um so
congratulations on your book I bought it
from my husband and he loves it you're
awesome thank you thank you thank you
nothing says I love you husband like uh
here's a book about anxiety you should
probably read it's true it's a true
story um okay so I I have never talked
about this with anybody so I'm gonna do
my best to get through this without
crying yeah hey feel free to cry away
cry away okay thanks okay so I have been
married for about 12 years and um before
we got married um my husband had told me
that he had had an issue with porn um a
very significant issue uh went back to
um the age of nine uh when he started it
was given to him by his dad um his mom
died
traumatically and that was one of the
ways I guess his dad taught him how to
cope with his pain so they never talked
about the grief and the trauma or
anything he basically just went to
alcohol and gave my husband porn so um
we talked about that before we got
married I was very clear that I am just
not the kind of person that can really
handle having that as a part of my
marriage and he agreed he'd gone through
a lot of um healing and like group work
um and therapy to try to work through a
lot of like the reasons behind why he
used horn in the first place so fast
forward about three years um he started
getting a little bit different and I
felt like something was off and so I
confronted him about it and um he was
using erotica at the time um and
masturbating um privately to that and um
around the same time also had like a
significant moment where he became very
suicidal I had to call his therapist I
had to call the police and remove the
guns from our house and have them sent
to the station and um the police showed
up at his work to make sure that he was
safe um so we worked through all of that
his therapist worked through that with
him and things got a lot better so fast
forward another uh 3 years and I had a
similar feeling uh that something was
off again and this time found out that
he was masturbating again at the time he
was actually using porn but did not
communicate that with me in a way that I
realized that that was going on I
thought it was just
masturbation so worked through that uh
no suicide or anything at that time no
significant issue of depression and fast
forward again and here we are for the
third time and um this time there's not
porn involved it's just solo
masturbation but I noticed him pulling
away from me and um just not being
present with me and um I'm so sorry no
don't be sorry don't be sorry take your
time and now this time there's you know
the the suicide um thoughts back and the
significant depression and and I am at a
place where I you
know screw me when shame on you screw me
twice shame on me kind of thing now
we're here the third time and I'm having
to carry all of this and I love him and
he's truly a really good person he is a
a nine on the aces score and has a
significant amount of trauma in his
background and he has worked through so
much he is um an amazing father and a
wonderful person and I don't know what
to do like how do I I guess my question
is how do I support him and not become
bitter and take care of myself and not
wonder why does this keep happening
because they're must be something wrong
with me yeah why this keeps happening
you know I I am a five on acis um so my
trauma is not as bad as his as far as
like I didn't lose a parent and all that
but I did have significant like child
abuse and sexual abuse we don't we don't
compare trauma on this show trauma is
trauma is trauma is trauma so um all
right so can I hop in here yes please do
okay number one you don't say this out
loud very often do you I never talked
about this with anybody I'm really proud
of
you
thanks so tell me you're either being
flooded with oh my gosh I can't believe
I said that or you're being flooded with
relief which one is it I feel relief um
go you'll feel guilty later you'll feel
that weird over like over vulnerable
like ah you'll feel that later but right
now I want you to I want you to fully
feel this for one second okay okay
because this is going to be part of your
path
forward okay is you have to stop keeping
secrets from him and from your small
group of people that you trust deeply
okay that's part of that feeling that
you're carrying all of this by yourself
it's too
heavy okay and you're not protecting him
and you're not protecting this image of
a marriage that everybody thinks you
have and honestly you're not protecting
your kid or kids by holding all these
secrets okay
okay so I want you to feel how good this
feels just once to say it to a like a
somebody that you know um you don't know
me but you know I'm not going to be mean
to you I'm not gonna be like oh my God
like that's not gonna happen okay yeah
now I'm gonna talk through a couple of
things and I'm going to give you
probably some advice that nobody has
given you yet okay okay and I also want
you to know that it may may be a
disaster okay okay cool but when things
are a
disaster I tend to head into them not
away from them okay okay so number one
you started this whole conversation by
telling me that his dad gave him
pornography as a way as a in as a form
of a drink when he was a child yeah the
complex it of his trauma is very layered
right mom passes away dad becomes an
alcoholic dad hands him pornography
pornography and masturbation at 9 years
old becomes a self soothing like a way
to disappear from any sort of pain right
yeah how old are your
kids um six8 and 11 God help y'all right
so you have a six eight and 11 year old
right so that means you have have a
fifth grader a middle schooler and in
the middle somewhere um and every dad
feels um less than every dad feels like
they should something should feel
different they should be more engaged
with their kids not enough working more
not working more
whatever and his body taught him at 9
years old this is how you deal with this
some dads work longer some dads join
fantasy leagues some dads work out too
much some dads play video games some
dads what like they just crack beers on
the couch your husband's body taught him
at a young age via his dad through some
gnarly trauma that this is how we deal
with this stuff
okay I tell you that to tell you none of
this is about
you okay my guess is your trauma as a
little girl you learned to solve that
trauma by making sure that everybody was
okay
mhm and this one's not about you and
that's
hard
okay here's the second thing for some
reason I to say that this young man has
has put in the work he's put in the work
huh he's put in a lot of work okay yeah
I want to try something that's unique
number one we're not g to screw around
with suicidality okay never ever ever
ever ever any hint we're calling
everybody any hint we're calling
everybody okay
MH
um but it sounds like if I look at
Trends okay and these are multi-year
trends for you it's happening again and
again and for me it is a lifelong
addiction to pornography
masturbation that goes to erotica just
reading it mhm which goes to had a m a
mess up not suicidal just just G
to now a guy just jerking off in his
bathroom right
yeah on a trend line that's a guy that's
doing a lot of work okay and I don't
have a problem with a guy masturbating
in his
house like that that doesn't tell me
that there's something broken in a
marriage that doesn't tell me
anything okay okay that and so here
here's why I'm telling you that I think
the approach is let's remove the shame
from that particular
act and one of the ways to do that is to
invite yourself into that
moment you see what I'm saying how do I
do that like hey next time you are about
to take masturbate take care of yourself
by yourself can I join
you okay I did do that I did tell okay
tell me about that how'd that go um fine
I I mean I don't think I mean I think
that's what he's done
since I think did did it demystify it
that's what I'm saying did it dhame
it I don't know I I'm not sure okay for
him you mean did it
yes I don't know if it did or not okay I
think it's worth the follow-up
conversation because there sound like
again I haven't talked to him it be
completely unrelated but it sounds like
somehow this shame and this loop-de-loop
and this trauma Loop are all wound up
together if these depressive Cycles
follow these patterns right and he ends
up in this dark place
yeah but I think I think the the the
helping part of you is to be curious not
oh my gosh my marriage is falling
apart
okay okay you have drawn a hard line of
pornography and I fully agree with that
line and so I think his work is not
Crossing that line because I think
that's very fair that you drew that
boundary I'm proud of you for that okay
okay the second or the third or fourth I
don't know what number we're on um
is me asking you are you
done no I don't get in your voice that
you're done I get in your voice that
you're just so
exhausted I'm tired I'm just really
really I just feel like I can't because
I because of the um suicide feelings I
can't talk about my feelings without him
shutting down so you know what I mean
like yeah he does have a lot of guilt
and I don't I don't know how to navigate
that what are your feelings that he
shuts down
from the shame
I think he feels he feels from what he's
told me like he's not a good husband and
that's not true sure but major
depression doesn't tell the truth and
it's just so hard to waade through right
is he is he taking his meds is he taking
care of business on that front yes and
they just started him on another one
okay and when they do that they off what
they tell you to watch real closely
right yeah they're adding on like
augmenting therapy instead of switching
okay so okay
so I guess the are you seeing somebody
too I don't know I mean I have a
therapist she's $175 an hour and to be
completely honest I love her and she's
amazing but she's so expensive and our
budget you know is tight and I that's a
whole other topic
yeah um is your husband
working um well kind yes and no yes yes
he does work but I've had to go back to
work full-time because of the industry
he's in it's just he's in the mortgage
industry and it's not going well right
now right so um it may be time for him
to change careers
dramatically because he's in an industry
where the best of the best of the best
are really struggling right now yeah
right and if you have a history of
really struggling and then you're
surrounded by people who are
struggling it may be time for that to to
that conversation see what I'm saying
yeah I think that could be a really
important moment for
yall yeah we've had that conversation a
lot actually um and depression gets on
that Loop and it sticks and it sticks
and it sticks one of the lies of
depression is the way you feel right now
is your fault and it's always going to
feel like this yeah right and so there's
something about shaking the snow globe
and saying let's do something different
let's make a move and let's work on that
together I I get that it's expensive if
your counselor's
wonderful um I think it's worth putting
some money on the
table and E even if you give it six more
sessions and I know that feels like a
million dollars with three kids and a
husband who's just not bringing home any
money because there's no deals being
done in his industry right now um he
might find he might find a ton of
purpose in driving Uber in the morning
or in the evenings figuring out some way
to make some extra money
um or you guys sit down and figure out
like hey let's look at other Industries
let's look at you know Bank whatever
else I don't know what he's qualified
for but
um I think there's something really
valuable in purpose and that stuff it's
starts a compound itself like I don't
want to go to work and then I'll stop
making money and then that depression
gets heavier and there's something about
taking baby steps out of that right out
of
it
um but I think it's worth taking six
sessions on your end and going to your
counselor and saying I need some very
specific guidelines on how to walk
alongside my husband during this season
when he's feeling
low and if you want to invite him into
that conversation I think that would be
wonderful because what you'all need to
do is come up with a few strategies so
that he
knows shame doesn't fly in our house we
don't have secrets there's nothing to be
ashamed of I'm proud of my husband and I
love my husband he's done a lot of work
he's inviting me into some very intimate
moments in his life in his life but
beneath that is this sense that hey we
got to get a job we're making some money
we have to redefine purpose in our house
and I'm with you and so when I turn the
lights on it's not to shame you it's to
invite
you and I think it's bringing that more
and more to the light and so if he'll
come with you on a for a couple of
couple sessions as y'all practice
learning new ways to talk to each other
that's great he's got to pay close
attention to that depression medication
I think that's that sounds like where
he's at right now he's had a rough rough
go of it his whole life and man I'm glad
he lives in a moment of History where he
can get the help and care that he
needs I don't want you to give up on you
all right
Barb I know this is hard to talk about
you've got to find a group of women that
you can sit down and speak with they
don't cost 175 bucks an hour even though
I think coun counseling is important
right now
call two or three or four women call
them together for coffee and say hey
it's vulnerability time I got to let
y'all know where I'm
at